i think if you spotlight both the
virtual yeah
vanessa can you hear us can you share
your screen as well
okay
all right
okay so i guess i will take questions
for all three of our panelists
yes one
microphone
so the first question is for joja
so you see that you have this structure
for your compounding factors
and then you'll be able to get some
reasonable like identifiability
conditions
that reminds me of the independent
component analysis when you have a time
series structure
and you can do the gaussian world with
the dependencies and but in
independent component analysis they also
have this non-functionality
assumption also give you some
identifiability there so wonder
what you think the non-culturality might
also help you
in the spatial case to get
reasonable identifiability
so this is can you hear me i don't know
this is something that i've been
thinking a little bit more recently
because i saw this presentation by jonas
peters that
he talks about how having extreme
observations can help you learn causal
relationships more
and i think that that's related to the
lack of gaussianity essentially
so
um
[Music]
i don't think it's necessary i think
that perhaps by having lack of
christianity we can look at these tales
and learn something that we cannot learn
with christianity i think so i i don't
know
i've read that paper but i don't know
much of that other literature and that
about the time series
problem you bring up
i think those two problems are very
related
essentially the way i understand spatial
confounding now
is that essentially you want to get rid
of everything that is structured
so that the in the you can essentially
use
the
independent residuals of an exposure
model
and regress your the independent the the
independent residuals of your outcome
model and those residuals or the
exposure model so i think that this is
essentially the
connection for time spatial and i think
also network data that as long as we get
rid of everything that has a structure
that what remains
um
is has to be the exposure effect
and um
there was something else i wanted to say
so i think that that's the connection
that
comes to mind i don't know if that
answers your question
thank you
thank you so i have a question for
huck
so um
you know you you showed us that it's
very important
uh to pick you know your s
s demand
um and even the different you know
finite population versus super pop pop
population how all these different
variants you know estimators behave in
very different ways
uh depending on the assumptions that
you've like made
um
and there's a lot of nuance here and
it's nice to see it all in one place
um
i guess i'm i'm wondering um
like
i've i've not talked to
you know people that run large scale
experiments too much
but i'm wondering
if people
you know
might say oh i don't want to have this
kind of nuance like i like i guess i
just want a one-size-fits-all
approach
to me that seems like it can't really
happen you know based on all of the
nuance that that you've shown us here um
have you had conversations like that and
if you have had conversations like that
how do they tend to uh work work out
so
i've
i've had a few in my collaborators had
more because he um works on he works on
the ground he works at mdrc where they
basically do these sorts of evaluations
all the time and he's
one of the people that people come to
bother when they're trying to figure out
what to do or they just need an answer
for something so they can go about their
business
i would say
i actually
secretly in my heart feel that there is
a one-size-fits-all answer for most
cases which is
to just fit the finite sample person
weighted
estimate
i don't believe
in the ability to generalize out of an
experiment in any kind of reasonable
context these samples are always
convenient samples they're not
necessarily representative of the target
population it's rare that there is a
target population
um
that anyone can really write down which
means
and also in the social sciences we
struggle so much figuring out if things
can work at all that asking the question
did it work for the people that i tried
to impact feels like a big enough
question to keep anyone busy
um
this is not an answer that people really
like that much telling them that
generalizing is just not a thing is
really
that's a difficult conversation and
because of that there's this large
uh literature about generalization where
you try to re-weight your sample to
match the characteristics of the
population and so on so forth and you
make a series of heroic assumptions
along the lines of most
quasi-experimental assumptions to say
that it's going to be fine
and you get bigger standard errors which
probably are going to hedge your bets in
a nice way
um
but
at the end of the day i think
and and that's the conversation i think
to have with uh in at the intersection
of this work which is to use an
estimator that's assuming your sample is
a super population
a sample from a superpopulation i think
is a very lazy way to go about
generalizing and we should possibly be
dissuading people from that and instead
saying okay if you want to generalize
let's do that as a second step and talk
about what it means to to
um
that being said
there's a lot of strong arguments i've
had with other people saying well
actually people aren't going to do that
so having a standard error that at least
generalizes to something is better than
a standard error that people are going
to very quickly forget means that you're
only talking about the sample that you
have
and i think that's also a strong
argument so i find myself confused at
that point and then i sort of go off and
to a corner in sulk but so that's my
current thinking on the pro
problem and i'm all excited to talk
about it ad nauseam as to what the right
thing to do is i think your question is
really right on in terms of where we
need to take the field in terms of
applied practice
thanks for the question
my question is for for vanessa
um and i'm coming from this from a
potential outcome framework
perspective and there might be some
aspect of the tag formulation that i'm
kind of missing in some assumption or
some idea
but um and i like that the emulating
trial perspective but you're talking
about hypothetical interventions so
you're imagining some intervention that
might not
exist today but could exist some at some
point in the future
and from my perspective it seems
that
if it is a hypothetical or an abstract
intervention those there's a big space
of possible social interventions and
those the big space of postulated
ventures could have different effects
so in what
but it seems like you're defining a
specific effect so how can we think
about that specific effect
in that space of possible hypothetical
interventions i don't know if my
question makes sense
i think as the
the more specific you can be the better
because then you know
more specifically what you're actually
talking about
if it's very very hypothetical so you
know there's a scale of
very specific to very very very
hypothetical and the more specific you
can be the better you can talk about the
assumptions and whether they are
plausible or not and the more
hypothetical
things become
the more difficult it is might be to
justify the assumptions or you know it's
you know you're talking about something
that's very vague and
very in the hypothetical future so
and it's a it's a matter of of the
subject matter and i've tried
to um give
real examples not just you know not just
where it remains entirely hypothetical
but where
um
people have thought about what the
different components are and when you
um some sometimes as i say as i said in
my talk
sometimes it's useful to think like this
and sometimes when you talk to people
who do mediation analysis
and you ask them why do you want to know
this
then they do come up with a story that's
exactly a
separable effects you know they talk
about different treatment components
because most treatments that we look at
in practice
really
are
do do consist of several things you know
every treatment itself has if it's a
medical treatment has the
active ingredient in the placebo effect
for example that's already two
components you know about being treated
and you there's actually some chemistry
going on
that's already two two different
components
so when
when you ask really why are people
interested in things then
some of the time
i wouldn't claim most of the time that
they come up with a separable effect
story
so this question is for luke so i really
enjoyed the talk and really just the
distinction of between all the
design-based ways and the different ways
of estimating uh effects across sites
uh one thing that i wanted to ask is
something at the very end of your talk
about cover adjustments so
uh i noticed sometimes
first i guess one specific question one
general question one specific question
is related to in your
work and maybe in other words work that
you've seen do people adjust for the
cluster size as part of the covariate
adjustment and the more general question
is when you think about cover adjustment
and multi uh multi-site trials do you
i notice that when at least when i talk
to some profes some applied folks
there's a they try to distinguish
between cluster level covariates and
individual level covariates and i know
those two things could have different
impacts and inference and i just wanted
standard errors i just wanted to hear
your thoughts on those questions thank
you
that's that's a great question and i was
a bit glib with the covariate adjustment
so
with covariate adjustment we focus on
adjusting for individual level
covariates when you have a site or
cluster level covariate for a multi-site
trial if you actually think about
since you randomize within the site
whatever impact that covariate is going
to have is going to automatically get
canceled out if you look at sort of the
treatment and control difference within
the site
the way you can actually include a site
level covariate
to improve precision in a multi-site
trial would be in principle to include
it as an interaction with your treatment
effect to try to model the treatment
variation across the sites
but
as far as i can tell that doesn't seem
to increase precision unless you have
very very strong relationships for
estimating that overall average impact
so
there's a there's a side project which
i've it has stalled on my part of trying
to think about what do you do with
covariates in a multi-site trial when
you randomized at the individual level
are those site level covariates useful
including cluster size like what how how
can you exploit them to to do something
if you're interested in treatment
variation i think you can look for
relationships with respect to those
covariates but if you're just interested
in some average treatment effect
i'm not sure what they have to offer but
that's an area that i'd i'm just
ignorant i i'm still thinking about what
that means
this is a question for georgia um
i really like this sort of connection
between spatial statistics and causality
and i know very little about spatial
statistics so in some sense this
question is naive or perhaps more more
uh philosophical and
so can you say a little bit more about
how i'm supposed to understand um a
spatial effect so what i'm wondering
about is that to what extent
is the space actually causal or to what
extent
is the space a proxy for other causal
effects that are at play
and
so in it's really a conceptual question
if you could comment on that a little
bit of how i should think about that as
separate or the same as the causal
effect
um
okay so there's kind of like two parts
to that question uh the the second
answer from that
is um how does space play a role is it
an effective space or is it an effect of
the treatment itself it's connected to
the previous question
if you essentially get rid of all the
special information from your data then
it's the treatment that is left that
could have the exposure effect
that could have an effect
but how you define it i think actually
so if you have a binary treatment i
think it's one thing if you have a
continuous treatment i think the
estimate definition plays a big role
because i don't think that
it's necessarily reasonable to think of
y
z with z being the same for every
location
so if your z is a continuous exposure
that is spatial i think if you wanted to
talk about the causal effect of that
continuous exposure
you would have to
to consider alternative little z's that
remain spatial and perhaps resemble
these
delta interventions like ed kennedy has
this paper that like perhaps like shift
the structure up and down slightly
that's how
but i think that that's related to how
you define causal effects in the spatial
setting
the and the second part of like how
actually you deal with space
the way i understand it i understand it
is the safest way to separate exposure
in space is by ensuring that your
exposure
has in reality some
independent component in it
that if the exposure itself is perfectly
spatially smooth
then you cannot really separate them
without assumptions on the
range of spatial compounding like you
can assume that your
spatial confounder only varies at
like has like a decay with a range
parameter that is something
then you can regress that part out but
if if your exposure is perfectly smooth
and you don't want to make any
assumptions
i'm not sure that there's much progress
you can make
i have a question for luke but also on
this topic of spatial structure
um so perhaps one heroic assumption
that gets appealed to for
generalizability or in a super
population framework
is that of spatial structure across
sites maybe related to covariates and
sites and this kind of heroic assumption
gets
maybe a little bit more in the machine
learning and domain adaptation
literature imposing some kind of metric
structure on the outcomes or the
covariate distributions across multiple
sites are there situations in which
it is possible to use more of that
structure where that those assumptions
may be more appropriate than in other
settings
do you think and and this is perhaps
related in spirit to a lot of
multi-level modeling and hierarchical
assumptions but
perhaps of a different flavor
but
i think i i missed it so you're saying
in the context of a multi-site
experiment where the sites themselves
have a spatial orientation with respect
to each other
am i following you
yeah yeah whether there are situations
in which that kind of spatial structure
could be
more closely leveraged or whether that
is more closely related to like
interference modeling or exposure
modeling
i think i think you would end up in that
case you'd end up with like
interference modeling which is
which then
introduces a lot of complexity that
i've always been personally afraid of so
i don't have much to say about
whatsoever
um that
there is something very attractive about
the i
i do think that there's
spinning your question a little bit i i
do think that there's a lot of cases
especially in quasi-experimental um this
shows up a lot in
spatial
iv designs and things like that
instrumental variable designs where it
feels to me like the spatial structure
is ignored um in a lot of what you see
out there and what's being done in
practice like people sort of get a bunch
of their units that are arranged
spatially and then they neglect that
spatial relationship
in the analysis and i would really like
to see that come back
but some of what you're saying also
sounds like
where you'd use the spatial structure
and try to estimate treatment effect as
a function of location
thinking looking for sort of treatment
variation along spatial lines which i
also think would be an exciting
direction but i don't
off hand
i i i think there is work on it but i'm
just not as intimately familiar with it
i feel like i haven't really answered
your question but that's what i got
so here's a question or maybe
clarification for luke so if i
understand correctly you are doing a
very nice stability analysis for
different estimates and different
methods
other
methods kind of follow the same
estimates
and can be because when you have data
especially when the design aspect is
very unclear their
practitioner probably i'm not using
different methods to to make a decision
right
and one question i was asking if you
like in our pcs frameworks i usually try
to screen the different methods
using some reality check say prediction
and then look at stability analysis do
you think that's a relevant angle for
what you do here
like if some of the measures don't
really fit the data then why do you care
about
how the estimates turned out
i know some of the design will eliminate
some of the competitors but
i'll assume that
they could be competing
estimators giving a data set
so
so i think
in in this particular context one of the
nice things is that the design behind
the data is usually very very clean like
um
you've identified the the sites and the
randomization of treatment within the
sites is
understood to like people do a good job
actually randomizing so it really is
a driver
um of your
uh it
it allows you to directly get your
causal effects without worrying about uh
confounding
that being said my
given
i like the idea of the screen and i
think we sort of did a baby version of
that by sort of identifying that some of
these estimators like of all the various
ways of estimating data
we identified that some of these
estimators are after a different thing
than than other sets of estimators so by
dividing the estimators into sets i
would say that the stability that we
really care about is how much we see our
point estimates and inference changing
within all the estimators that are
aligned to estimate the same s demand
and when the s demands are different for
example if
going from finite to super or vice versa
then you would see these radical changes
but we have an easy explanation for the
radical radical change which is that
they're actually answering different
questions
so
of all of the things that we identified
as reasonable ways of of analyzing the
data
i would say that we find a pretty good
amount of stability in most of the
contexts the the one exception being the
super population site and perhaps there
are other estimators that can be used
there that would be
um more stable or that there would be a
way to get a handle on the instability
and that's an interesting question
and
an area that deserves further thought
yeah i think the screening with the kind
of
type of problem i think is very nice one
but i was asking more like do you worry
about before you go for this
estimate to see in general does the
model fit the data
oh like do we do model checks
yeah um
we we didn't we just sort of applied the
models
because all of the models you can
most of the models aren't really relying
on very many parametric assumptions so
in principle
asymptotics is going to kick in unless
you have pretty serious outliers
because of the randomization the
randomization saves you from a lot
it would be
interesting to
to go back and some of them some of the
models do
at least nominally make
parametric assumptions
again in practice it seems like
randomization allows you to ignore
violations of those but
that's something that i'm saying
feels true rather than a strong
statement so it's probably worth looking
at that more carefully
thank you
thank you this is a question for vanessa
um
on your last slide or towards the very
end of your uh presentation you have the
comment that um
your
the account you give is restricted to a
single world
so i was
wondering whether you could comment a
little bit more on that and to what
extent you think that sort of
restriction is important or
should be paid attention to or that it's
what is its value to
stick to the single world
well so
in the context of mediation uh causal
mediation analysis you have these
crossword quantities where you imagine
the treatment is being said to one thing
and the mediator is being said to what
it would be had the treatment been
something else
which
is not only a long sentence but it's
also complicated to think about and
involves uh assumptions about
these these cross-world quantities so
what would happen with the same
individual under one setting of
treatment and the mediator and the other
setting of treatment etc and so by
thinking um about it with the separate
components of the treatment
um
like um
jamie ellia and thomas described it in
one of their recent papers you can think
of it as a forearm trial
and that would be something like a
target trial that we could do in this
world in a single world where you can
sep
so you have these components of
treatment and you
uh think of the two values for one
component the two values for the other
and all together you have four
combinations so it's a forearm trial
and um if that is meaningful in the
sense of as we were discussing earlier
less
on the specific side and less
hypothetical side you can think about
this trial and maybe even carry it out
in in the future
in a single word and that helps i find
it helps to think about the plausibility
of various assumptions that you need to
make in this case for the
identifiability
is that answer your question
it's very weird to not be able to see
the people who are asking the questions
and to see whether they are nodding
okay
you and luke are larger than life so we
see you very well
i don't see and should we okay so thank
you to our panelists and thanks
everybody and
that's it for now and we'll be back here
in at 2pm right yes we have last session
at 2. thank you
thanks so much for having us
thanks